[Music]
lacey is in denver hi lacey how are you
good thanks for taking my call
sure how can we help
um i have a question about baby step
five
um
my husband and i are out of debt we have
a an emergency fund
we are rather behind in retirement
um
and we have we have six children four
are adults
and they
are in or have finished college all on
their own they got into they got a
scholarship they had part-time jobs
internships
on their own debt-free
either have finished or are in process
of that
we also have two younger children who
are only in third and fourth grade and
our income has
increased dramatically
um so for the first time i feel like we
really have the ability to actually save
for college for them
but we're kind of debating whether or
not we even want to do that
because it's been so good for our older
children
we're not i don't know it's ethical to
just say we can but we're not going to
pay for college sure
it's ethical
definitely ethical
it would also not be unethical to just
pay for college
okay
i mean unless you raise some entitled
brat i think paying for college you know
they're it's not going to change their
character whether they pay now you want
them to have some skin in the game
that's what i'm hearing
yeah i do you treat college differently
are you worried about what the four
older ones will think
a little bit
yeah
well i mean it's it's it's okay to have
an awkward discussion with the four
older ones in the room one time but like
like at christmas go hey guys we need to
have 15 minutes awkward everybody hold
your breath you ready
here we go
fair is where the tilt-a-whirl is and
they have cotton candy so let's talk
about fair
how would you feel
because now we make more money than
we've ever made before if we were to
actually financially help your little
brother and little sister where we
didn't help you how would y'all feel
about that let's just talk about it
by the way you don't really get a vote
we're just asking for your opinion
and have an awkward conversation and get
that out of the way i'll tell you what
you might learn
you might learn that they say this was
the best thing that ever happened to me
and you go you know what i i don't i
really don't want to steal that from the
little ones i'm going to make them work
their butts off too or they might go you
know it was okay we got through it but
it kind of left some scars and i love my
little brother and sister enough if you
pay for part of it it'd make me happy
they might
say either one one of them might say one
thing the other one might say the other
is that right
yeah possibly yeah
you just had pictures of their faces
flash in front of your mind and went
that one's going to say that no one's
going to say that you just did just now
i watched you do it
i think you're saying it with black and
white options of a or b
why not have the money there and have
parameters around it and say hey we have
30 grand per years per year you can go
to the state school if anything beyond
that you pay for and you're going to get
a part-time job and still apply for
scholarships but our kids have had some
fun adult discussions the uh oldest is a
daughter the middle is a daughter and my
youngest is my son and they've had some
fun discussions in our presence where
denise is like you know
i i couldn't do one tenth of the things
you got away with little brother
you know because they were hardcore
and then you know and and so
and you know what they all survived and
they don't like each other less and they
don't like us less because of it there
was no malice involved but by the time
we got to the third one by the time you
get to the sixth one
you know some of your energy runs out
and you're just like oh whatever jump
off a cliff whatever you're gonna do go
go play with a lawnmower it's okay i
mean you know whatever it is you're
gonna yeah whatever you're just a little
bit less freaked out the first one
you're like oh god they're near the
kitchen you know it's like and so you
just
and you're much we were harder on our
oldest discipline wise
and i think we got lazy or we started
figuring out it wasn't all necessary or
whatever i mean we weren't like super
hard on one and not hard on the other
one oh they all had to behave but you
know i i hey fair is where the tilt
award and the cotton candy is i mean
it's you don't get fair
so i think you're doing okay either way
it just i probably really good family
exercise to have a fun
over thanksgiving discussion instead of
getting out john deloney's conversation
cards use these use this right
and so the key is to have a conversation
and have some fun with it and laugh
about it and because listen you make a
lot more money your life is different
than it was when those kids were this
when your oldest one was in third grade
you have a you're different people your
different life you make a lot more money
it's a different situation you go on
better vacations now
you go out to eat at better places now
uh and those kids get to ride along and
the older one didn't and so that's how
life work it's okay it's it's all right
you're not a bad person either way yeah
it's not unethical ethics are not on the
table here um
but i know a lot of people that are
hardcore and say yup not paying for any
of it it's good for them just got it out
i'm gonna coach you i'll be your biggest
cheerleader but you get nada you're
going to figure this out i'll show you
what to do but i'm not signing any loans
and i'm not giving any money so here's
what you do you need to get some
scholarships a job and go to a school
you can afford and they start laying it
out ahead of time and puts the
parameters and you know like you did
with your oldest ones and you could do
that there's nothing wrong with that
there's also nothing wrong with paying
for college
ethically yeah which is i don't think
it's going to create a bunch of brats i
think what she's wanting is the
character that it created to have them
at scholarships and part-time jobs
it's good and uh
just to position that while we're having
a discussion and not really part of our
answer but just all three ramsey kids we
paid for the college but there were
parameters
lots of parameters parameters are you're
going to live on the budget and here's
the amount you have to live on it's not
it's not opulent um and um
you're going to uh you're going to be
walking
a values-based life that aligns with our
family value system
uh which we're christians so that would
include welcome of god
and so you're not gonna be off
misbehaving uh going bananas out there
okay and and us writing checks for your
misbehavior we're gonna fund your
misbehavior not likely not going to
happen
so uh you know you're going to you know
going to be doing that and
and they had to finish in four years is
that right yeah they had to finish in
four years and they went to an in-state
school and uh so we weren't wasting
money
and so um so if rachel said dave i want
to go to a private school
in a different state not paying for it
actually she had a different she did not
was worse than that she wanted to go to
an out of state university in the sec
that was not the university of tennessee
which is somewhat like blaspheming but
yeah no
yeah we just shut that heretic down
right quick
because it was uh i mean it was like 3
000 bucks or something at that time to
go to ut
and it was like 14 000 to go to this
other sec school which will not be named
which will not be named um but she the
only reason she wanted to do it was she
thought it was cool
it had nothing to do with nothing that's
how it's 17 11 000 because you went
across the state line and got basically
the same education i don't think so at
17 you're not doing math you're just
picking the coolest option that's it
well rachel it would just be i wanted to
be different
i don't want to be like everyone else
well she's accomplished that yeah she
has accomplished that and made a brand
out of it it's pretty good i'm proud of
her